nous présentons nos condoléances à la
famille Windsor mais nous ne nous sentons pas obligés de
pleurer la reine Elizabeth II
étant donné qu'elle a présidé de nombreuses
atrocités en Afrique
[Musique]
donc
le pardon est dans la Bible
je suis chrétien j'y
crois
mais
je ne le suis pas  je crois
en l'oubli, personnellement, je
n'oublierai pas
que j'ai été incarcéré
pendant sept ans,
je ne peux pas oublier que
j'ai été mis avec mon père,
je ne peux pas oublier,
j'ai laissé mes enfants pendant sept ans
sans nourriture,
sans éducation,
je n'oublierai jamais
[Musique]
notre famille  subi beaucoup d'
indignités, de dégradations, de morts et toutes
sortes de choses à cause de l'
asymptote coloniale du colonialisme et
de l'intervention de la Grande-Bretagne dans les
affaires africaines, en particulier au Nigéria.
[La musique]
traite tous de la même manière
les têtes de nos ancêtres
britanniques.  des musées dont nous avons demandé à
maintes reprises d'être rapatriés au
Zimbabwe et cela n'a pas été fait et
enfin nous avons demandé
des réparations pour tous pour tout ce qui
a été pillé dans notre pays et nous
n'avons jamais obtenu de réponse de la défunte reine
est mon devoir le plus douloureux
de vous annoncer le décès
[Musique]